parejo steckt und was genau den
schweizerisch an diesem sein soll
am anfang war die idee und die idee war
bestechend ein paar wie der im verlauf
der weltausstellung aufgegessen werden
sollte
bestehend aus für die schweiz typischen
nahrungsmitteln den zwei architekten des
bislang kaum bekannten büros netwerk kam
ihre idee am küchentisch welternährung
das war ein thema zu dem sie ein klares
statement abgeben wollten das war noch
wirklich auf das thema spielt und eine
dadurch aber allenfalls kritisch war so
entwickeln sie einen pavillon mit 4
seitigen türmen in denen in handliche
portionen verpackte nahrungsmittel
gestapelt sind
jeder besucher darf sich mit ihnen
nachgefüllt wird jedoch nicht wer viel
für sich nimmt lässt weniger für die
nachfolgenden der politisches abbilder
verteidigungs klammer geist zusammenhang
systemische und und eigentlich jede
einzelne jeder einzelne konsument
sie stehen männer natürlich einmal ganz
minimaler maß doch im fertigen papillon
werden nur nicht käse und schokolade
angeboten sondern ganz andere
lebensmittel trinkwasser mit
mehrwegbecher salz kaffeepulver
getrocknete apfelringe
eine auswahl bei der nicht zuletzt
haltbar kriegsgründe mit spielten für
den auftraggeber die amtsstelle präsenz
schweiz verkörpern gerade diese produkte
schweizer tugenden wichtige botschaft
von hanna trinker von der brenner hat
trinker und unterm schloss nach salz
interessant natürlich
doch es hatte viele diskussionen
gebraucht bis sich alle beteiligten auf
die produkte geeinigt hatten
denn ernährung ist ein hochpolitisches
thema erst recht wenn konzerne wie
nestlé den pavillon mitfinanzieren
da prallen unterschiedliche haltung und
interessen zusammen mit russland
schweizer aus unserem druck aber mit
ruft schweiz im ausland zu
repräsentieren
das ist natürlich so dass auschwitz
marketingtechnisch erspart es im park wo
auch in trance hat schließlich aber hat
man einen gut alt genossen konsens
gefunden
nun soll der pavillon im ausland die
schweiz repräsentieren nur welche
schweiz
schon frühere weltausstellungen
transportierten ganz unterschiedliche
schweiz bilder etwa die schweiz der
technischen innovationen 1958 in brüssel
die heidi schweiz als lockvogel für
touristen in shanghai 2010
oder doch eher die provokativ
selbstironische schweiz 2003 in sevilla
asketisch wurde es im jahr 2000 in
hannover
der pavillon von peter zum tor war aufs
minimum reduziert denn schon damals
meinte zum tor weltausstellungen es sind
überholt oder ein überholtes konzept da
heute per mausklick jeder beliebigen ort
der welt erreichbar ist
doch in mailand wird einmal mehr keine
mühe für die kommende expo gescheut
was zeigt dass dieser anlass als
gigantische standort marketing plattform
immer noch gefragt ist
gelegenheit für die schweiz der welt
ihre essenz vorzuführen
die swissness der uniko quartal
projektbeteiligte so zusammen und dann
eine kleine ok aufgab des wissens frog
vermehren was ist wissens und denis
gesprochen oder wie das heißt das was
ich stelle was ich stimmt wissen es ist
sicher sehr sehr klare architektonische
sprache zu wissen es besteht darin dass
musik ein stift mit prädikaten berichtet
ikea will ihren sie
erzieherisch seriös glaubhaft konsens
orientiert
die ausländische besucherin soll die
schweiz so kennenlernen und der
schweizer mit gestärktem
selbstbewusstsein nach hause gehen